Good afternoon.
Welcome to the very short NCBI minute on alerts
for new data.
As per usual, this recording as well as the
slides will be available both in the YouTube
channel, the webinars playlist and on the
FTP site.
You can find the links here.
I will give you a minute to copy the links
down.
(https://go.usa.gov/xXqGG)
So over the next few minutes we will talk
about setting up alerts for new data using
My NCBI.
I am Ben Busby, the bioinformatics training
lead here at NCBI, and I have with me Peter
Cooper who is the head of the NCBI education
group.
Many of you most likely use NCBI literature
resources.
Many folks are very used to using My NCBI
to do regular literature searches.
However many of our users do not know that
you can also save searches for data.
For example, for new assemblies or annotations.
For new Geo data sets or new SRA data sets.
I will walk you through how to do that over
the next few minutes.
The majority of you probably know that MyNCBI
is simply a way to have an account at NCBI.
It's trivial to sign up for a MyNCBI account.
In fact, when I was preparing this webinar
I signed up for a MyNCBI account.
Simply so I could have a fairly clean demonstration.
It's reasonably an easy thing to do.
There are many folks out there with MyNCBI
accounts.
I encourage you to get one.
Creating alerts from any search string at
NCBI is simple.
Really all one needs to do is click the create
alert button below the search they are already
doing.
Say I was searching Geo for Alzheimer's and
human.
You may only have one data series as shown
here.
I can click the create alert button.
The alert dialog box would come on.
I can modify my search term and I can name
my saved search.
I typically use the defaults but if you do
a lot of these I could see that you want to
name them in a more systematic way.
You can either keep the filters or not.
There are a bunch of ways you can get email
updates.
This is really quite simple to use and a lot
of people have told us they would like to
see this service which in fact exists.
As I mentioned earlier, you can also get alerts
for bacterial annotation and assemblies.
This is useful in my opinion, in the microbial
realm.
For example, if I want to see new releases
of Salmonella, either assemblies or annotations,
I can do this search in the NCBI Assembly
database.
I believe, the NCBI Assembly database is a
very clean and useful resource for finding
genome assemblies.
Also if you were to do SRA searches, for example
for meta-genomes, you could do that.
The search I did here was for digestive decontamination.
It's a fascinating thing that is sometimes
done to folks, patients in intensive care
units.
Here you can see a time course of such experiments.
Interestingly enough, you can blast into this
time course to look into different bacterial
gene loci that return to the gut after this
massive course of antibiotics.
I can save this search simply by clicking
on the create alert icon.
Another nice thing that MyNCBI will do for
you that many folks don't know about, is it
will save custom tracks.
Both track configurations that you can set
up in the NCBI genome data viewer by clicking
on the Tracks button, but also data that you
upload.
Here I uploaded a file called test.bed.
And MyNCBI will save that.
As with all of our resources, we have documentation.
You can get those from the NCBI Learn page.
If you Google for NCBI webinars, it is an
easy way to find the webinars page.
My favorite way to get to this documentation
page is to go to NCBI/learn and you will be
able to go to the documentation.
Once again, an updated version of these slides
will appear on the FTP site in approximately
one hour from now.
Some of these links will be more simple.
Another thing I do in my position at NCBI
is I run Hackathons.
We have a bunch of them coming up and if you
are pretty familiar with Linux and can do
some basic scripting, if you are interested
in bioinformatics or medical informatics,
you should consider coming to one.
These are the Hackathons that are coming up.
Some of them look very interesting and there
are some shaping up for spring of 2018.
In my group I also have intensive internships
for grad students, postdocs and clinicians.
You can come here to work for 4 to 6 weeks
on either your project or ours, in a collaborative
environment and leverage NCBI resources.
We ask that you document the stumbling blocks
that you run in to at NCBI.
If that is something you're interested, in
please email bioinformatics-training@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
With that, what I want to do is take some
questions, any questions you may have.
If there are questions that I do not know
the answer to, we will either answer them
on the FTP site or Peter Cooper can answer
them in person.
I see no questions in the question pod.
It's obviously a pretty simple and straightforward
NCBI minute.
If there are any questions I will give you
the next minute or so to type them in.
If not, I hope you all have a good day.
A fantastic rest of the week.
Thank you for coming to this NCBI webinar.
If you have feedback about the webinar, you
would like to see more, or would like us to
dwell longer on a specific thing, please feel
free to email webinars@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov or
put those comments right here in the questions
pod.
Fantastic.
I don't see any questions.
Thank you to those who said thank you.
Like I said, I hope everyone has a fantastic
week.
Good luck with your research or whatever else
it is you do.